welcome back okay in the last segment we
coded up a genetic algorithm to optimize
a PID the set of PID control gains the
proportional integral derivative control
gains to minimize an lq our cost
function for this transfer function G
okay so we coded this all up we ran it
now what we're gonna do is we're gonna
there was this output function that
saved all of the intermediate
generations and individuals all of that
data so now we can start plotting and
analyzing what this actually did over
this genetic optimization so just I'm
gonna rerun this one more time because
it looks cool and I want you to watch
these 250 control laws being runs so
these are all of the step responses it
starts off trying a bunch of things with
high cost functions because they're
random PID gains but then even after a
few iterations a few generations will
find that this J starts to hone in on
much better control laws that are pretty
similar and then it tweaks those
parameters to get better and better
performance so we'll just let this run
for a minute we'll see that it is kind
of converging into these optimizing
values of PID using these genetic
algorithm operations mutation crossover
replication and elitism okay so it
should finish soon notice that now the
cost function is kind of hanging out
around 1.5 sometimes it gets a little
bigger because of the mutations and
things like that but really you know now
we're honing in on parameter space where
where the algorithm is is good okay it's
done and so you know it spits out the
best PID gains in the specter X and the
optimal output value in F Val so if I do
F Val
that's 1.49 in this case so you know
slightly different than the last time I
ran it because it's work there's some
randomness to it but you know around 1.5
and so now if I go to this function you
know genetic algorithm PID plots what we
can do is load we can load all of the
data from this last run and I'm going to
load my history map
file and start plotting stuff okay so
you can check out this code and see
exactly how I call everything and plot
it but I just want to walk you through
some of these some of these outputs so
here what I'm doing is I'm plotting over
I'm plotting all of the individuals all
25 individuals for each of my 10
generations and I'm color coding it
these are sorted in order from best
performer to worst performer in that
generation color-coded by the cost
function so to is small cost function
these are good performers and yellow are
bad performers these are big cost
functions very bad control laws and I
might have cut this off because some of
those objective functions went up in the
thousands I might be lumping those all
in these super bright yellow ones okay
and maybe this is a long plot I can't
quite remember but anyway the basic idea
that you get is the the dominant trend
is that as the generations progress this
becomes more and more blue which means
that more and more of the solutions are
getting low cost function nearly optimal
performance the first generation had a
lot of pretty bad performers because
these were random but then even in the
second generation I have maybe half as
many bad performance than less and then
almost none at all the next thing we
observe is that even though in our
initial population we had some decent
performing algorithms it's also getting
darker blue as you go to the right which
means that these are getting more and
more optimized from generation to
generation
so sometimes what people do notice that
this actually does kind of rely on
having at least some good performers in
my initial generation so I need some
good performers here so that I can kind
of breed them and mutate them to get
more and more optimal solutions later on
and so sometimes what people will do is
they'll actually start out with a bigger
initial population maybe you know two or
five or even ten times as many for the
initial population to do a big Monte
Carlo search to try to find these
hotspots of good performance and then
they will decrease over time and
essentially have less and less
individuals per generation and as you
start to hone in okay so this is the
simplest case where I have this flat
structure
every generation has 25 but maybe I
would get better performance if I had
the first generation with 50 or 100 ok
so that's a cool plot we can see in time
in generations it's getting better and
better which is quantified by this kind
of trend towards darker and darker blue
ok good ok what are we gonna plot here
that's not great
population size let's load my R and pop
ok
essentially this just has some of the
parameters from the last from the last
run so the population size is 25 pop
sighs okay pop size equals 25 let's try
that I just cleared everything so it
didn't know how many individuals they
were per population okay so now what I'm
plotting is red are my initial
generations and blue are my later
generations and I'm plotting the actual
P I and D values for all of the
individuals in all of those generations
and so here what you can see initially
you know I started in this cube of PID
and so my red points initially are kind
of scattered everywhere but over time
they converge into this hotspot right
here which is the best-performing kind
of group of parameters and so all of the
kind of purple and the more blue it gets
the later the generations the more it
hones in to this sweet spot in parameter
space where you get the best performance
so you can see this thing swarming and
converging in to the parameter values
that optimize okay good so now what I
want to show you are all of my
individuals from generation 1 and we're
going to compare that with all of my
individuals from generation 10 so my
first generation here I mean you can see
that it's pretty terrible right this is
my cost and it goes up to 400 so some of
these are kind of blowing up actually
this is not cost this is my output okay
this is my output response so my step
response sorry this is a typo this
should be why the output of my system is
kind of below
which would correspond to a very large
cost in my first generation so you can't
really see it but if you zoomed in there
might be a few stable PID that actually
give you a decent trajectory but a lot
of the individuals are unstable and
terrible in this first generation those
are kind of corresponding to those
yellow really bad cost performance in
the first slide and now that I think
about it that must have been on a log
scale okay let's contrast that with the
individuals in generation 10 okay again
this is a typo this should be the output
response Y but now you see by generation
10 all of the PID control laws that the
genetic algorithm is selecting are
stable and actually a lot of them have
the same basic you can see this kind of
band here these are all just variations
on a nearly optimal parameter value and
then it's also exploring some other
options that are maybe suboptimal okay
but there's a pretty tight band of
responses that all have very low cost
around kind of 1.52 you know one point
five to ten ok nothing really really
huge so this is the last generation
that's already honed in and found that
best set of optimizing parameters and
then maybe one of the last things I'm
going to plot the best individual from
each generation so there will be ten
plots the best generation from the first
all the way to the best generation best
individual from the last and again I'm
starting with red as my initial
generation and blue is my final
generation and so you can see you know
the red ones are they've got a lot of
variants and a lot more oscillation but
eventually they hone in to this very
tight band of purple and blue signals
these are the responses my control input
is a lot smaller also it's the blue ones
a lot smaller control cost and then the
overall integrated lqr cost here over
these ten generations goes down
significantly almost by a factor of two
okay so after these ten generations my
cost really is reduced and I do get a
better a better PID output response
okay so this is one of the things you
can do if you output your data through
these these populations these
generations of individuals you can then
start diagnosing what was my learning
rate how how effective was my initial
population how good was my first you
know the best performer in my first
generation and things like that so
genetic algorithms are super powerful in
MATLAB really easy to apply all you need
is a function that evaluates and gives
you a scalar output number that should
be minimized and this will run through
and find find those optimizing values
okay so you can try this on your own
control system all of this code is
available so you can kind of try this
out on this example and probe and make
your own plots and see how it works okay
thank you